the Justice Department is accusing
Huawei that Chinese tech giant of
criminal activity in the US 23 charges
and two indictments were unsealed
yesterday in Brooklyn New York and
Washington State the charges include
bank and wire fraud obstruction of
justice and violating sanctions Jan
Crawford has read the indictments and
has more for us Jen good morning well
good morning the charges come after more
than a year-long investigation into Wow
way as affiliates and its top financial
officer the Justice Department is
alleging that the world's second biggest
maker of smartphones stole trade secrets
from t-mobile and violated US sanctions
on Iran both sets of charges exposed
Huawei's brazen and persistent actions
to exploit American companies and
financial institutions
FBI director Christopher Rea did not
mince words calling Chinese tech giant
Huawei a dual threat to America's
economic and national security in an
effort to build their own robot wall
ways engineers allegedly violated
confidentiality and non-disclosure
agreements with t-mobile the indictment
say Huawei employees undertook a scheme
to steal t-mobile's robotic technology
named happy employees allegedly took
numerous unauthorized photographs of
tapi and secretly removed a part of it
from a laboratory in Washington state
last month Huawei's CFO Mong Wan Joe was
arrested in Canada amid a US extradition
request according to one of the
indictments Wan Joe misled banks about
one-ways business dealings in Iran which
led to a violation of US sanctions in
September Norah O'Donnell asked director
ray about huawei's growing influence as
a global telecom giant is this enabling
or allowing China to conduct espionage
around the world the telecommunications
infrastructure is something that we are
so dependent on in this country and the
idea of letting the Fox in the henhouse
is something that I think people need to
be really really careful about now
China's foreign ministry is calling the
charges an unreasonable crackdown on
wall way and the company said it did
nothing
wrong the White House is insisting that
the charges are not connected to trade
talks here in DC this week between US
and Chinese officials Norah that is a
very big story indeed Jim thank you so
much